winter sports reigned supreme on the
Zugspitze a' germany's highest mountain
close to the Austrian border at
altitudes over 2000 meters the 20
kilometres of slopes have natural snow
for six months of the year offering
enthusiasts splendid conditions for
downhill racing but if you want to
really stand out from the crowd you can
build your own snowboard or skis like
these participants in a two-day workshop
in fire hunt near the Bavarian town of
garmisch-partenkirchen learn how to make
the models that suit them best off the
rack so to speak you can't always buy
what you need I'm relatively small but I
can't use kids boards because they have
smaller feet now I can adjust the width
and size and that's very good I have
absolutely no idea how skis are made
it's really exciting to learn how much
technology there is in skis the self
built ski starts with a base around
which a metal border is formed then
comes the wood core it's bolstered with
two wood strips to give the boards the
necessary tension workshop instructors
Mishael Aiden shank and axle for Kalla
mainly use ash wood a long fiber wood
that is tough but elastic
mikono hoods shouldn't Foreman you can
shape the wood well and it gives you a
really good resilience it's very
malleable so you get good tension in the
ski when isn't that enables us to adjust
the ski was great my decision to see
what the customer wants I understand
what a cool new is getting hit there
between the layers come sheets of glass
fiber fabric the students learn how to
attach them with a liquid adhesive then
the length width thickness and tension
of the ski are adjusted to their
individual needs
and finally it's time for the personal
design whether a glass of the skiers
favorite brew or photos of friends then
the skis and boards are vacuum packed
and placed in an oven for curing at 80
degrees Celsius this is enough for
Wednesday this is one of the advantages
that we have compared to store-bought
skins we can really adjust hours to
every person who comes to us and
couldn't hide uh packing skills where
they want to ski
we have enough parameters so that we can
bury them in order to individualize the
skis after they've hardened in the oven
for 14 hours the skis and snowboards are
almost ready they just have to be cut
out of the form using a jigsaw then
edges are sanded down to remove any
excess material and unevenness now all
that's left to do is mount the bindings
I'm really pleased with the result my
patterns aren't perfectly centered but
apart from that it's a great ski I had
problems curving the edges because I
couldn't get the arch right at first and
I had trouble cutting it out when it
came out of the oven it was the first
time I'd ever held a jigsaw but I would
they did an okay job except Arella self
built skis are ready for a run on the
slopes he tests his products regularly
up to now he's built 2,000 skis and can
look back on a decade of experience
let's go krinkle there is no cookbook
recipe for making a freeride ski or a
slalom ski it requires lots of
experience lots of days on the slopes
with our experience in building and
testing skis we've compiled a little
one-to-one ski construction method with
a bespoke pair of skis or snowboards
under your feet there's nothing to keep
you from heading downhill this winter